oh it's Mom okay hey Mrs C we were just
in the middle of eating Jesse what do
you want for Christmas I already have
what I want true love
Jesse I think I'm holding you back are
you breaking up with me
[Music]
baby we did things right you know we
kept the fights clean and the sex dirty
I mean you keep that [ __ ] is so fresh
I'd be happy to keep servicing your
needs if it will complicated things
I just spoke to my son right breaking up
with you right before Christmas yeah
Sean doesn't want to come home that's
fine but your family
it feels right to be here
hello my name's David
and Liz got a few two years younger we'd
have to try not to get pregnant
hey Becky nice to see you remember when
we were kids I made my whole cookie jar
at you I should probably help with the
uh life
have you been standing here the whole
time hello yes
I hope Jesse's having a good time
they're having fun now take a sip of
purple drink is this safe just enjoy the
moment have a nice glass of lean
together
something this spontaneous and forever
way more cough syrup at the moment
soda it's very full body
is it too much
not at all now she is trying to bang
Sean's cousin we are dealing with a
chopped Chef Christmas slot
foreign
[Music]
it's like it's meant to be
whichever path you take I support it
I know that Sean can be wild sexually
and I want you to know
that comes from my side of the family
I'm sorry
thank you for sharing that with me
it's important that we stay connected
during this busy holiday season so drop
those lights and pull out your dick
foreign